[موسيقى]
بعد 11 سبتمبر أصبح السيخ هدفًا لجرائم الكراهية
وشعرنا بالحاجة إلى القيام بشيء ما
في تلك المرحلة ، فكرت كيف يمكننا
التفاعل مع مجتمعات أخرى مع
أشخاص آخرين من ديانات مختلفة وتثقيف
الأشخاص الذين يسعون لذلك فكرنا جيدًا من
أجل  مجموعة الدراجات البخارية يعطي والدي
للناس وجهة نظر مختلفة ،
فنحن لسنا أشرارًا ، فنحن رجال طيبون
[موسيقى]
فرسان السيخ في أمريكا هم
مجموعة من الدراجات النارية يرتدون عمامة ويسافرون
عبر البلاد لتثقيف الناس حول
ديانة السيخ.  تم تشكيلها في عام
2012 بعد أن دخل مسلح إلى معبد
السيخ وقتل ستة أشخاص يقدر عددهم
بنحو 250 ألف سيخ يعيشون في الولايات
المتحدة ، وهناك جزء كبير من
جيراننا الأمريكيين الذين لا يعرفون
من هم السيخ الذين يؤمن الديانة السيخية
بالمساواة للجميع  ثم خدمة
الآخرين لديّ خبرة أكرهها فقط
لأنني سيخ وأبدو مختلفًا أن
ركوب دراجة نارية هو أحد أكبر
الأحلام الأمريكية للسيخ وهم محاربون معروفون
في الهند كنا دائمًا  ركوب الخيل
والدراجات النارية هي خيول العصر الحديث ،
وهذا أحد الأسباب التي تجعلنا نرغب في
البدء ، لذلك لديك شيء مشترك
[موسيقى]
كل عام ، يقوم فرسان السيخ الأمريكيون
بجمع التبرعات لجمع الأموال للجمعيات الخيرية المحلية التي
تتمحور حولها جهات جمع التبرعات
قيادة الدراجات النارية المجتمعية إلى
المتنزهات المحلية كان الناس بدورهم
يختبرون رقصات الطعام والتقاليد
من ثقافة السيخ
ويحرص غوريندر على نقل
عمله إلى الجيل التالي
وقد تم تفكيك خطتي في ركاب المرضى في
أمريكا منذ أن كان عمره ست سنوات
لقد ذهب إلى ملاجئ المشردين
لإطعام المشردين وأعتقد أنه سيكون من
الرائع حقًا أن أكون قادرًا على نقلها إلى
ابني عندما
أرى والدي يفعل هذه الأشياء يجعلني
أشعر بالفخر لأبي وأعتقد أن ما يفعله والدي من
أجل  يلهمني الأقل حظًا
لفعل الشيء نفسه حتى أتمكن من متابعة قيادته ،
إنه حدث الجميع ، فأنت
جزء منا لأنه بدونك
لم نتمكن من القيام بذلك شكرًا لك
شخصيًا لقد رأيت العديد من الأشخاص بعد ذلك.
لقد التقوا بنا تعلموا المزيد عن
ديننا ومن نحن ، لقد
غيروا وجهة نظرهم في النظر إلينا
لقد أحدثنا تأثيرًا كبيرًا على
المجتمعات التي نعيش فيها
وتمكنا من تثقيف الناس في جميع أنحاء أمريكا
[موسيقى]